in csgo there are good plays there are
great plays and then there are plays so
memorable so iconic that valve has
chosen to immortalize them in a very
fabric of the game I'm calling for the
score eSports and today we're taking a
look at the incredible plays behind CS
goes and map graffiti and signs now for
this installment of best of guys we
chose to ignore goofs on dust2 and the
bird boost sign on train while they do
have their own cool stories associated
with them they're not backed by the kind
of incredible plays that we're looking
for in this video now let's get things
started with what is perhaps the most
iconic of the iconic graffiti spray
plays holds eras jumping pop there he
comes once again the first base is
attorneys gonna hit the ground there's
cold on the semifinals of the world
tournament the biggest hunger strike
firm would have ever been 10,000 fans in
the first American major the crowd was
so loud was screaming luminosity was
down to two liquid everything looked
like it was a low-key and called Sarah
defy the gaming panics by jumping and
taking a shot killing not only one of
his opponents but two with one bullet
was hard at play of people on the window
here it comes once again the first base
is the trainees gonna hit the ground
there's cold jumping over cold
this coolness safely velocity with the
own plane thinkable seems that the
apartments hold on to device around the
world we go over the diffuse the diffuse
is coming in is how to control your
nerves in the situation dance it out but
I cut and then the diffuse to get around
fifteen in the fire
we should really rename this map to Olof
pass right yeah like we were always talk
about ninja defuses in the smokes now
right and now there's a whole new metal
I'll just stand in the flames it doesn't
matter man someone get the fire a suit
in the fire and pretty man wait don't
give
septuple smokes in the same place
my favorite moment as a measure it's my
double noscope I played for Team Liquid
against fnatic at ESL one cologne and
every member of my team just was so
happy every crowd member will.shaw happy
his first time in a dysfunctional say
like a few months I did tattoo to remind
me that moment here's like Angela's
wings
he was like his eyes no scope and here's
a bullet your shots that I'll never
forget in my life
now guys not every incredible play does
get its own graffiti spray some get a
sign like the clips in our next section
I am excited because I heard a rumor
that fnatic have some crazy stuff
planned on this map oh my god this is
beautiful to try and surprise ldl-c
through this world we don't even know
what it is so this is pronax being a
genius they did warn us that they have
been planning something it doesn't tell
us that much but they were being very
secretive about it and I don't blame
them something like this had never
really been seen before and a long time
of counter-strike human dating the
previous versions so things had to come
together at the same time I thought was
the second map they might still be in
the series where he got in three maps
you know all these unfortunate things
had to come together together at the
same time and at the worst possible
because this was the time based on how
it was going they were gonna be fine I
all of my sisters still waiting the
patients came from a hidden spot I'm
coming out of squeak toys while he's
here he sees them now they're straight
headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed then
this
here's shimmers whoa
finally warrants and now phonetic this
is the comeback moment for them this
would be absolute history in Calais
right the original maids they're thrown
by an F to try and hold them back all of
us will find the shot on the exists
Freiburg does return picks off pronax
he's still here though and he's going
for more to big Frank's that third man
is here over at Rebecca st. gold-headed
lay fiber old yesterday stay alive it is
gonna be great
Paul he picks up a quad kill he can do
even better than stagger lives headed
that lightly shot find work and now
Freiburg is taking a bit of the fetish
spot right here they're gonna try and
flash their way through this could be
perfect this can be too perfect the
double spray the troubles by Friday you
think that's forbidden bananas in here
so if you need bananas Freiburg put on
as you will guess I enough fat banana he
was really excited it'll work honey bond
release energy folks it's good and with
that said I recently research into
bananas and apparently you have to be
overpowering to dictate their pace
remember that smoke is gonna be very
annoying for them smoke it get right in
perfect position as well this could be a
complete massacre here get right picks
up afraid they're gonna commit their way
through private picks up three in a row
make it four prime Oh excellent defense
they're up and honour just at you as you
would expect an ni p take the first one
on the second half there could have
forbidden banana fingers well portals
now they know what to do to challenge
mr. darling position the gambit has sent
even more firepower that's ring boy mr.
Sabich suit
jet flame jordu schell with it don't
that so smart
I've never seen uh before coming into
that position you can't survive in a bit
but anyone's gonna round him coming and
throwing the AG grenades and that's rock
just the bomb goes off at all it takes
to both down so he doesn't get the fraks
for it but he denies them so much money
going forward as well that's one of the
sickest I did now valve removed this
next graffiti when dust2 was overhauled
but that doesn't mean the play behind it
isn't still worth remembering look at
the guns like Oh
aw peas romantic they're ready to shoot
some ducks as they cross the middle it's
gonna be a challenge and not in this
lifetime
he is destroyed well when they're lining
up like that you know you're in trouble
JW already insights and look at what
apex sees here viable thing to do on the
overtime rides a ballistic or excess
cash so just going for that initial kill
through the doors there allows them to
drop the aw peas and go into something
very faster than acid
both the initial strikes and then they
pushed him to be straight off that well
guys that's all I got for you this week
if you've got an incredible play in mind
that you think valve should immortalize
in a spray or a sign let me know in the
comments below and I will see you next
week thanks for watching if you want
more great content just like this be
sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]